all right before we move on okay like i
i like i
i'm wondering why okay before we get to
halo wars i'm wondering why you put apex
over over league
all right okay is this is this recency
bias
i think there's definitely been a
recency bias um i don't know for me
league of legends was fun and i really
really really enjoyed the time i had
with it and
it could easily be on here yeah i think
apex is on here just because like
i don't know apex made learning japanese
fun for me
okay like isn't that isn't that fun yeah
because you're actually using it right
yeah and like
for me apex has been such a door opener
like right now like it's just like
everyone's playing apex right now and
like it's so easy to be like yo playback
just jump in
you know yeah like uh i don't know just
anyone it's like
especially japanese or like youtubers
it's like yo let's play apex
um i don't know it's so fun and i feel
like it's it's like
even though i just started playing it
recently i have been playing it i did
start playing it at launch
right and i feel like the game's only
gotten bigger and better now and i feel
like that's rare
for games especially battle royale like
i feel like it's more popular now than
ever
yeah yeah and it's [ __ ] massive in
japan
yeah yeah um youtubers man they they
just completely broke the system yeah
it's crazy i mean you know it's it's
crazy seeing how like
when it came out you know the story of
apex is that they
they literally announced apex legends i
don't know if you knew this
a day before it came out oh [ __ ] really
because what happened was is that it was
made by the same people as titanfall
right so ea thought it says published by
yay but it's made by respawn the people
who made titanfall who made call of duty
modern warfare 2 back in the day
so you have that you have that clean fps
gameplay combined with a nutty movement
of titanfall
yeah um and yeah so what happened was
that they literally were just like oh by
the way isn't it
because they thought it was gonna bomb
because it was made by the same people
who
had made titanfall yeah with no titans
in it yeah
and everyone was like yeah i'm not
playing that where the [ __ ] max the
mechs are the best part
yeah but yeah no it was a surprise hit
it [ __ ] blew up the game play's so
[ __ ] clean like i mean i i've
like from what i heard apex was just
battle royales but just was with every
mechanic refined
it's so good it's so fun and you know
it's really like
weirdly one of the most beginner
friendly battle royales i think yeah
well what i want to know is has it
gotten to a point where everyone's just
really [ __ ] good at the game yet
no there's a meta and everything's
broken the matchmaking is surprisingly
good like when i play ranked i
really struggle like against people my
own level when i go in like normals if
i'm like playing with uh someone who's
like got a really bad stats it'll like
even us out like i can feel like a god
but you know so in other words yes but
he's on the other side
no no no no because i'm playing
you know i play with some people who are
like you know arguably have no hands
yeah and they seem to have the time of
their life right
and i you know to me i would be like
that's not fun but they seem to you know
they
again people who you know because it's
such a position heavy game it's not
about mechanics
it's more about do like okay are you if
are you standing out in the open and
someone else is on the high ground
shooting at you you're probably gonna
[ __ ] die yeah
but like you know it you don't need to
have like aim god cs go [ __ ] that's like
i hate that [ __ ] fortnite felt like that
as well like i feel that like
if you just have like some form of game
knowledge which you can easily learn
you know it's easy and all the
characters are really unique it's really
fun like i don't know it's great i
really think you guys should try it out
try it out with me apex stream literally
every episode every episode i'm gonna
keep saying it until
trash taste apex when it's good like and
legit like i've made so many
new friends from it and yeah like the
other week 47 of asking the boys to play
yeah literally
like and so the other day i actually met
up with people who i met up on apex i
met on apex
with two japanese guys oh really spent
the whole night trying to talk japanese
it was very like taxing my god i
realized
i was an hour into talking only japanese
and i was like
[ __ ] i had to do this for like another
four hours of like not being able to
communicate
yeah um it will do wonders though for
you oh no it was definitely helping like
i feel like i definitely have like the
basics
completely locked down like it's all
muscle memory like i could just say [ __ ]
just talk nonsense you know that's good
stuff oh chinchin big you know
all the stuff you need so that
yeah yeah it was fun you know it was
just crazy to think that i met these
guys from just chatting [ __ ] on a video
game literally just going in a lobby and
screaming broken japanese
and then i was hanging out with them you
know that's cool yeah it was just chill
like i think
it's all about the friends we made along
the way you know i and honestly
which you can't say about league of
legends exactly i have made friends from
league of legends but
like it just felt like i can't imagine
making a friend from a guy you met in a
lobby in league of legends so
well that's the thing it was always
weird friendships with them like with a
with it because it was always like we
were the same rank we played ranked
together yeah that was this weird thing
of like that that was what it was and we
were like our friendship was
tangential on the fact that we were both
the same rank and we were good enough to
play together
yeah yeah but in apex it's like oh you
know i you know i play with a guy who's
called kyochan he's like a 45 year old
man
right in like west uh japan who's
[ __ ] awful at the game
but he's really funny and so like that's
like you know i i like playing with him
and it's just like there's no it feels
chill it's a really chill game but it
can be a really intense game if you want
it to be
yeah and it's like perfect because it
has like enough lows in it where you can
just talk
and then when the moments where you're
like fighting it's like right let's
focus on fighting all right
so that's why it's on there i
legitimately think it's the best battery
i've played i've played so many of them
it deserves to be on there it's a
[ __ ] great game player pex legends
um and finally halo wars i'll quickly
talk about this i played
i have probably put more hours into any
game here halo was probably
the game i put most hours into really
why halo wars
i don't know what it was it was me what
made me fall in love with rts's that
game was
terribly unrefined and and awfully
unbalanced
yeah and you know i've never played wars
but that's all i've heard about yeah
that is like
extremely unbalanced i think it was the
case of i was very fortunate that
my my four like i had three best friends
and we all loved halo wars so as a case
of
every single day we just went home and
played halo wars yeah
and it was just like the perfect game to
chat to and also be like
you know all right do this do this yeah
i really like the idea of rts games
i like i mean i i remember playing
command and conquer
so [ __ ] much that was that was my rts
game but i i like i've never got into
rts
like more than just build a bunch of
soldiers and then click on
click on anyone who looks at you funny
that is that that's like my tactics when
it comes to rts games
i think the one thing that i really
loved about halo wars is that it really
did 2v2 and 3v3 wow
i can't think of a single rts game that
has 3v3
like can you name it it's always 1v1
yeah and like i find that
like boring yeah like the fact that i
can be there with my mates and we can
all back each other up and then like
yeah you kill one dude's army
[ __ ] his his friend's army is literally
coming to wipe you out and then you're
like bro bring in your army where you at
man where you at
what the [ __ ] that actually sounds
really fun because that's so funny i
guess that's the reason i never played
pvp in any rts even though i know there
is there i just played the campaign and
i'm just like i can complete the
campaign
and it's a chill game because it's like
the games were never more than 20
20 30 minutes they were normally 15 10
minutes so it was great because what
would happen is
like you know there would just be
moments where your mate
or there would be like all three of them
would be attacking your mate and none of
you are ready and you're like
yeah i'll see ya did i play [ __ ]
no i'm just realizing my my three by
three is a lie
why is red alert two not on my three by
three
that's a [ __ ] amazing game and not
many people remember it
halo wars 2 is pretty good it's on uh
you play on pc it's pretty good
does other civilization games rts yeah
they're like turn-based it's like almost
turn-based right because everybody
really likes that i played
two like [ __ ] crazy back in the day i
feel like it's in the category
it's in the category it's like a
different style like i play civilization
every now and again because
you know when you get that feeling of
just replaying a game every now and
again so
i get that with sieve sometimes and i'm
just like i play one game it lasts
it lasts like eight hours i'm like okay
i've i'm that's that that that's
that's my one out the window now i'm
satisfied yeah
yeah honestly halo wars is a great game
i'm sure if anyone played it
who like played it with mates i would i
would love to play an rts that's like
2v2 we could play halo wars i mean i'm
33 right i'm [ __ ] down for halo wars
well you got a beast pc now halo wars 3
is it on pc hello's two is on pc yeah
and it runs really well
i've got i've gotten so many games that
i just i'm i know i'm gonna go home
today and be like
okay i'm downloading all these games now
time to replay all these twenty songs
here's what we should do we should all
do like a a day where we all just say
like let's all play
each other's like choice of game yeah
sure you should do that